こんにちははじめ社長です今日はモンスターハンターダブルクロスの発売日
汗から後輩たちでやってまして今日
ごはんを1食も食べてません
なんかもぅでもね大型の政治家6判とろしくてもうご飯食べる暇もねーしちょっと
さすがに肌が減りすぎて死にそうだなということで今日のご飯を食べようと思います
最近僕思ったんですよナットうまくね
なっとって健康にもいいわけじゃないですか健康にもいいしおいしいって言ったらもう
しの打ち所がない人はネバネバしていると言えども僕これ一つで食べる必要な
いいと思うんですよ納豆って何かと何かを見合わせて初めて真の力が発揮されるもの
東部か思ってるわけでございます豪黒入りだで最近僕がハマってるのはカレーライスを
食べてるんですけど彼二に納豆をかけるとうまいねうまいねーよもう本当にもう
ドン引きしましたドン引きするくらい美味しくてカレーに納豆がなら結構なんでも合う
んじゃねーか雪が僕なんか出てきて
今回の中が減ってるんでいろんな食べ物準備しました結構仲良く皆さんが食べそうな
もんどこが準備したんですけども全部にナットぶっかけて絶おいしいんじゃないかと
いうパッチョ照明をしますもんな頭がなんたらナンバーワンだよホント健康にもいいん
でしょよくわかんないけどこれはワンチャンありますよねっとうざ決まってるだろう
人はちょっとネットで調べたら納豆をおいしいとありがとうみなさんにをせよまず
すごいこれじゃ
泥って書いてあったのがこちらごはんですよどうなんですよネットにかけると
めちゃくちゃ美味しいという話があったので実際にやってみましょう
正直納豆混ぜて暇じゃないんしてはもう版がねぇ
てもう待ちに待ってたマスクって今日の夜も
頑張るよってちょっと子判別をかけてみましょうか決議とまれなんでもこれぐらいにし
ておきましょうか不安ですよ乗りました
見た目はちょっとないはこれだけおいしいぞじゃあ
いただきマックスむらい
[音楽]
うまぁ別名のバランスだよって美味しい1品の食品で立ってますねうんまぁ全部食べ
ちゃった
そしてもう一つたまごたまごぶっかけてもめちゃくちゃ美味しいみたいな情報があり
ました
試してみました富士山病気のキャパシティが限界だわ見た目の後はないぞを書いてき
をいただきます
[音楽]
あーなるほどね爽やかな味わいになってましたちょっとご飯でしたかやばすぎて
ちょっと
なんといいんですようーん結局くっちゃうっていうねもう言われで分かったと思うん
ですけど何食っても美味しいんですよってことはこれをもせ今はなった悪いんだったん
ですけどメインが違うものでそれに納豆+という味付けのスタイルだとと変化するのか
見ていきましょう
まずはこちら牛丼10度んでしょ変な
でもトッピングしていいかあるから多分何でも合う山では行きますやー
俺は信じてるよな投球どうも信じてフリーターにマックスむらい
[音楽]
ううわあもう何も除名待って味うまいんだけど
柔道の勇様た史実で納豆会社もちゃんと出してた結果を爽やかに食べやすい lc 路線
の牛丼になった気がしましたねこれもう端近くでこれも次こちらナポリタン
雑穀からちょっと怪しくなってくるんではないでしょうか同伴じゃないからもう面です
かそれも日本の形では外国の方をお呼び
いいして今から日本のおもてなしをするわけですから果たして日本の
思っ
やりましょうおいまはないと思うじゃない地下皆さん
納豆もその日は無限大ですからねまあこれやべーな大丈夫かなぁん
聞いたこと台分ではいただきます
[音楽]
次行きましょうね
いやダメなのかな全然欲しくなかった全然部はずーっと合わなかったって明らかに
おいしいっていう感覚ではなかったパラ違いますね次々はこちら天津飯ごはん後のなん
ですけどもう街とあまりがないですが低周波ってこの甘めに納豆がいかに高校木を重ね
て新しい甘みになれるかどうかというのポイントでございます
いや
これは多分あっているといただきマックスむらいたらちょっとてっぺんをとって
いただきます
[音楽]
美味しくないん
日本中がのマッチングで3つおいしいと思ったんですけど予想以上にまずかった
これ俺の見方が間違ってなければ割とまずいっすよ次はこちらチーズバーガーです日本
ヨーロッパ中火と木たらも耐えばもちろん usa 製納豆ののさを知らしめてやり
たいです
納豆チーズバーガーです
でも食べていきましょういただきます
ran
me
んだべか
[音楽]
pr
ん
納豆はねぇ合わないのではないですね
いけると思ったんだかれいにゃんって歌ったインドと相性いいわけでしょインド大将
良かったんですよね欧州も中華も夢性も全部いけると思ったんですけども全然駄目でし
た北海の結果で分かったことはごはんですよとナット最高にうまい